welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my Mandalorian episode 3 video
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
probably one of the best episodes of the
season there's only been three episodes
so it's hard to say there's not a big
sample size but it's definitely my
favorite episode so far so we'll break
it all down all the Easter eggs if
you're new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes this season
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing a new Star Wars merch
yes there will be baby Yoda merch soon
so I'll explain that at the end of the
video careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
obviously we'll do top 10 and easter
eggs as we go along
starting with number 10 the title of the
episode is the sin it's a reference to a
couple of different storylines during
the episode - the Mandalorians sin of
initially leaving baby Yoda this
helpless creature with the Imperials in
exchange for this giant fortune and best
car it's also a reference to his sin
against the code of the bounty hunters
guild when he reneged on that agreement
to save baby Yoda later in the episode
because now he is the most wanted man in
the sector along with baby Yoda think
about it this way they activated all
those tracking bops at the end of the
episode it's only going to get worse for
him through the rest of the season while
he's on the run trying to protect baby
Yoda but right after they come out of
hyperspace baby Yoda jumps out of his
bassinet and grabs the ball on top of
what looks like the hyperspace Liebherr
that's very similar to the hyperspace
lever on the Millennium Falcon
just to play with it stick it in his
mouth they carry that moment forward
when the Mandalorian goes to activate
the lever later and sees that the ball
is still missing reminding him of the
kid before he goes back to save him and
then again at the end of the episode
when they pay it off when he detaches
the ball himself and gives it back to
baby Yoda to play with number 9 turning
over the kid and collecting his fortune
so the surface of the planet actually
looks really harsh all those red lines
give it a very mu stefarr feel like the
planet's surface is very very harsh
although I'm pretty sure this is not
moved too far the actual Mustafar planet
is way more red overall in color the
look of the kids faces they're walking
through the shipyards and the streets
seems like he's never been around so
many people and aliens in a city like
this before he's having this tiny little
panic attack while he's just not sure
what to make of everything they passed
the same street food vendor cooking
salacious crumbs on his spit
see way more different classic aliens
you see a to elect for the first time
that they later reference when they say
Twi'lek bathhouses when grief Karger is
telling him hey let's go to the spa
it'll be a great time making it sound
like it's more of a brothel than an
actual spa there's an r5 looking droid
that's colored similarly to the r5 droid
the Jawas tried to sell to Owen and Beru
Lars and Luke Skywalker during a new
hope that later comes back at the end of
the episode when it's trying to take
them to the shipyards before it gets
blown up by creep carga things start to
turn the minute he sees how the
stormtroopers are treating baby Yoda
just yanking him around trying to poke
him like it's a piece of meat even the
stormtrooper who yells at him for
questioning him sounds exactly like the
voice of the imperial officer during
Return of the Jedi that says you rebel
scum I wouldn't be surprised if they
actually did try to sample that voice
from the original trilogy because they
do that a lot with audio Easter eggs and
it's one of the most iconic Imperial
lines from that movie that people repeat
as dr. Pershing and Werner Herzog's
characters scanned the baby and get
really excited they give him his bounty
in bests car but when he pulls it out
it's the actual ice cream maker Star
Wars Easter Egg from Empire Strikes Back
if you didn't spot it or you're
relatively new to the original trilogy
movies when they're in Cloud City and
things start to go crazy you see this
character running in the background with
what looks like a giant ice cream maker
as fans dubbed it people just started
calling it the Star Wars ice cream maker
Jon Favreau brought it back for this
series during Empire Strikes Back nobody
knew what it was for but on this series
Jon Favreau has turned it into sort of a
portable lock box for valuables as he
starts to question their intentions
things start to get ugly Werner Herzog's
character questions his code
quote-unquote of honor as a bounty
hunter isn't this against the code of
your guild he also reminds him that most
of his people the other Mandalorians
were killed during the purge implying
that he might join them if he doesn't
get out quickly so number 8 the
Mandalorian enclave their codes his new
armor and the cygnets Mandalorians have
their own code about right and wrong
that's way more important to them than
any local laws or any of the laws of
other organizations like the bounty
hunters guild this is the way is the
line of dialogue that they repeat to
each other throughout the episode and
then again at the end of the up
so this is the way but he gets his shiny
new best scar Armour so everybody kind
of hates him because he looks so awesome
now the other Mandalorians are really
excited to see what's going on they're
really curious but also really upset
when they see the Imperial cygnets on
the bars these bars were stolen during
the purge
he gets the special new whistling birds
weapon for his gauntlet he used a bunch
of cool weapons during the episode but
it's just guided best guard darts that
detonate on impact they show you a ton
more flashbacks to the Clone Wars around
episode two attack of the clones you
finally see the larger battle droids in
the Droid gunship flying overhead so
it's just implying that this was
happening during the Clone Wars and you
finally find out why he hates droids so
much in present day because the battle
droids killed his parents
but number seven when the other
Mandalorians get pissed at him for
working with the Imperials in the idea
that they're just reclaiming best car
that was stolen from them during the
purge the Mandalorian in the heavy
infantrymen armor that starts to fight
with him is actually voiced by Jon
Favreau himself if you ever watched any
of the Clone Wars you probably remember
that Jon Favreau played the pre bhisma
Mandalorian character one of the most
important and powerful Mandalorians
around that era his family descended
from the very first Mandalorian to
become a Jedi
and that Mandalorian created a dark
sabered thousands of years ago many
years later after he passed away previz
TLAs family stole the dark saber back
from the jedi temple and used it as a
symbol to rally the Mandalorian clans
together after they'd been scattered for
years after the great Sith war with the
Jedi the dark saber is still around in
Star Wars Canon the last time it was
seen was on Star Wars rebels before the
events of a new hope being wielded by
Bogut and Crees one of the last known
leaders of the Mandalorian people but as
they imply several times through the
series under imperial rule their people
were also purged kind of like the Jedi
word during order 66 in the clans have
just scattered to the four corners of
the galaxy but the Signet that they
offer him for his armor is for the mud
horn you're allowed to wear the signet
of whatever you defeat in combat on your
armor but he forgoes it per the terms of
their codes of honor because baby Yoda
helped him defeat it which they sort of
incorporate with his arc during the
episode about saving the kid turning the
kid over then changing his mind because
he
my enemy helped me defeated so I'm not
allowed to take credit for the Mud Horn, my
enemy did not know he was my enemy when
he was helping me he's talking about
baby Yoda at this point is still his
enemy because he was part of the bounty
but obviously he changes his mind at the
end of the episode / the Mandalorians
code of honor
number 6 all the other bounty hunters of
the guild hate him he almost takes off
to the other side of the galaxy just to
avoid having to think about what he just
did
turning the kid over when he gave him
the bounty for the Mon Calamari saying
it's a nobleman son who skipped bail all
I could think about was that Admiral
Ackbar son has turned into a criminal
but I think this is just some sort of
random member of his race some new
character I believe that Admiral
Ackbar's son does show up during the new
Star Wars trilogy although Admiral
Ackbar himself went out in
the last movie so during this show he's
technically still an admiral because
this is right after Return of the Jedi
in the New Republic's fleet they also
finally referenced the actual New
Republic but mostly the Mandalorian
saying that it's a joke to think that
they would care what the Imperials are
the remnants of the Empire are doing
this far out on a backwater Outer Rim
territory it's funny to think that
people hated the Empire because they
were so terrible but they also kind of
hate the New Republic because they think
that the government still doesn't care
about them even though it's a completely
different group of people
number 5 he decides to rescue baby Yoda
so he listens in to Werner Herzog and
dr. Pershing talking about the kid after
he finds the bassinet in the trash
outside the office werner herzog is
arguing that he won't be able to protect
the doctor much longer and to hurry up
and get his sample and be done with it
which we later learn is code for end
the kid after you get your sample of his
DNA like dr. Pershing says he'd be dead
now if it weren't for me more on that in
a second because dr. Pershing survives
at the end of the episode so he's
definitely coming back but watching the
Mandalorians and mow through the storm
troopers like a terminator was totally
badass one of my favorite sequences
through the episode so far it's like
Darth Vader at the end of rogue one you
know exactly what's going to happen he's
just going to mow through all those rebels
with his lightsaber him going around
room-to-room also kind of reminded me of
Star Wars dark forces that old
first-person-shooter made in the style
of doom or Wolfenstein 3d that was such
a great game back in the day in major
bonus points for curry
use of grappling hook he had a lot of
really creative take downs during these
scenes he's also been a big fan of his
gauntlet flamethrower which he uses to
barbecue one of the stormtroopers I
think he's used it in every single
episode so far but number four doctor
perching in the kid is an imperial
interrogation droid in the background
just like the one from Star Wars a new
hope when Darth Vader was interrogating
Leia in her cell and just like that
scene they zoom in on the needle but you
also wonder if he was using this on baby
Yoda somehow how do you interrogate a
baby that can barely speak or more
likely it was there in the background
and they were using it for other things
on other people
dr. purging mistakenly thinks he's there
to get rid of the kid which lets you know that even though he's working with the Empire
on some sinister cloning project he's
not a total monster he cares about the
well-being of the kid so maybe he will
also turn later in this series and
actually try to help the Mandalorian
protect baby Yoda but the device that he
hasn't hooked into that's taking samples
is probably taking DNA samples for
potential future cloning in the episode
ends with them implying that he got all
the samples that he needed so this
cloning project can move forward and it
might wind up becoming something bigger
during a future season if they don't
shut it down before the season finale
maybe dr. Pershing will help out with
that but the only way to stop something
like that would be to destroy all the
samples or destroy all the research that
they generate from those samples number
three was the scene of them activating
all those fobs and the Bounty Hunter's
from the guild coming after him again I
love the slow scene of the cantina with
the Bounty Hunter's realizing what's
happening oh wait a minute the bounty is
back on the scene of him slowly trying
to walk out of town kind of looking
around noticing that all the other
bounty hunters are just waiting to make
a move is this great moment of tension
they have their big standoff Carl
Weathers grief carga calls him on the
code of the Bounty Hunter's guilt that
he's violated and just as he's about to
go down all the other Mandalorians
jetpack in raining fire on all them so
number two Jon Favreau's Mandalorian
infantryman leads the charge is pissed
off as he was at the mandalorian for
working with the Imperials earlier in
the episode their code is higher than
any other local law or the bounty
hunters guild so it doesn't matter that
they'll have to move their secret base
to another planet for their protection
this is the way we protect our own so it
doesn't matter what the Mandalorian has
done to break the code of the bounty
hunters guild or break in any kind of
Imperial or local laws the Mandalorians
will rally to help him no matter what
you get a sense for all the different
types of technology that they use almost
all of them besides the mando himself
have jetpacks they sort of pay that off
at the end of the episode with the funny
moment I got to get myself one of these
as Jon Favreau's Mandalorian jetpacks up
alongside his ship salutes him and then
goes back down to the planet even though
this was a huge scene a huge moment of
them all coming together and fighting in
a probably really expensive to film I'm
hoping that we get something even bigger
like this later in the season were more
Mandalorians rally to help him number
one they escaped but grief cargas
survives thanks to the best gar bars
blocking the blaster shot nice uses the
Carbonite freezing device to steam up
the cargo hold to get him but because he
and the Imperials are still alive Werner
Herzog's character is still alive
dr. Pershing is still alive they have
the research in the DNA samples from
baby Yoda things are only going to get
worse through each episode as the Empire
tries to get rid of both of them the
bounty on them will probably go up
they'll become more datoria the sector
as other bounty hunters from other
planets start to rally to try and take
him down but we're still not even
halfway through the season we still need
to meet Gina Carano spouting hunter
character and we still haven't met
Giancarlo Esposito 'he's Imperial moth
character yet and he's even more
powerful and seems like he's tied to
Werner Herzog's character and dr.
purging somehow as you would expect he's
also playing a very Gus fring like
character on the show well let me know
if he spotted any big easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't mention in my
video obviously my episode 5 video will
post next week I'll do more bonus videos
for the mandalorian during this week too
so if you have any special requests or
big questions you want me to answer just
let me know in the comments for those of
you asking about merch they did say they
would start selling baby Yoda merch
really soon so the giveaways will
probably be something for that stuff
once they announce what the actual merch
is going to be but everyone click here
for my new baby Yoda in Jedi history
video and click here for my
Mandalorian episode 2 video thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight!